listen i have a million questions for
you um let's start with the most
important thing is die hard a christmas
movie absolutely it's a christian smooth
christmas movie
yeah absolutely um
you know it's what's so funny is
uh
you know 30 years ago or 25 years ago it
might have been not a christian movie
but i mean christmas movie but but if
you keep switching your story around
people will continue the debate and
they'll keep you know watching it at
christmas time so
right at what point did you realize
it is crazy that your first credited
screenplay was die hard because
truthfully it's it's one of the best
villains in hollywood history it does
it's so such a phenomenal movie um at
what point did you realize this was like
an incredibly special movie
uh that that's that's a good good
question i it was it was
yeah you know the first time i saw it
the first time i saw dailies you know
the first time you know everybody needed
to make that movie i mean but the the
whole die hard thing is a whole nother
conversation
with love to talk to you about the
details about that but i'm oh sir i i
believe me when i say at another point i
would love to have a more in-depth
conversation also about the fugitive and
a whole bunch of other movies
so i've seen the first five episodes of
vikings valhalla i want to give you a
congratulations i watched all of the
original vikings i'm a fan of the show
and i thought these episodes were really
so well done um and i'm curious how did
you actually get involved was it netflix
coming to you did you go to netflix how
did this thing germinate
um
that's a really good question first of
all i was a fan also
it means a lot as a fan of the vikings
to hear you say that you know you found
valhalla a a you know the transition
between these two because they're two
different animals you know it's it
totally but
morgan o'sullivan who was an executive
producer on vikings and he'd worked with
michael hurst
um sort of brought me in they called me
up i knew michael we developed a show
together um but michael didn't didn't
didn't wasn't really part of that at the
time morgan just said look we're
thinking about continuing the story we
don't have anything you know we don't
really know what we want to do
um you know and i said i don't want to i
don't want to write season 7 of
michael's show you know that he it's
it's run its course as far as that's
concerned
fabulous show iconic great characters
you know the action's terrific um so let
me let me sort of putter around in
history for a little bit and see if
there's a place to come in
and i did that and did a lot of research
i kind of got my viking you know history
you know up to the point where i could i
could be you know stupid and uh and and
then i i found the saint bryce's day
massacre which you know is not a is you
know it's not a bank holiday in england
you know you don't really celebrate
those genocides but um but i thought wow
you know for me
that had some sort of you know cultural
resonance you know and relevance for me
that i felt like you could start a story
because we had pagan vikings at this
time and christian vikings and just like
in our culture you know you got the you
know republicans and democrats but when
you go to war when there's a 911
suddenly you forget your ideology and
you become american and you go out and
you you know you you're one people
and inadvertently king athered gave
king knut and we gave the vikings a
reason to stop killing each other over
you know religious differences
and become viking again and i thought
that's a very cool place to start a new
series
and then by bringing in freitas and leif
from greenland
i you know had characters that i could
bring in and suddenly bring an audience
up to speed 150 years later okay what's
it like how you know bringing two people
in who are outside of that viking
culture from you know from their great
great great grandparents day
so that was exciting for me and that
when i got excited then then it was you
know let me go
good place to go go hunting
i got
some specifics about the stuff when you
went into netflix and you get things
going did they say to you hey what's
your idea for three seasons what's your
idea for five seasons because obviously
they are not looking at this as a
one-and-done kind of a thing vikings is
incredibly popular around the world yeah
well i i wasn't um
i wasn't going to give him a chance to
say what's your idea i told him what the
idea was okay so because i you know
figured out if i'm going to tell this
story it's got to have we got to get to
the new world and we've got you know
because we know that and and there's
some certain things and harold siegerson
has an incredible journey of his own
we know that
uh we know a lot about you know
you know how the viking age sort of
moved through the 11th century and sort
of goes to
the battle of uh hastings and you know
1066 and william the conqueror
and all of those type of things which
has incredible viking roots you know
william the conqueror is
the great great great grandson of rallo
so it's you know there's all of this has
this nice wonderful symmetry to it if
you know if you can start to bring it
together so
to your point i said here's what the
first season is here's what i'd love for
season two here's where we take the
story
in success into a future area so i'm i'm
hoping that you know people like
valhalla because i love this journey and
i'd sure love to have an opportunity to
complete it
trust me when i say man as i said i've
watched all of vikings there is no way
fans of that show are not gonna respond
to this one
zero percent um how many episodes is
actually season one i know that it's
eight episodes do you consider eight
those eight season one and then the next
eight season two like how does this work
yeah yeah that's what it'll be it'll be
it'll be that classic netflix eight
eight you know type of type of thing at
least it is with my show and so um
uh and and season two will have a
different
vibe to it you know the same characters
moving through the story progresses
linearly on that path but they're you
know the characters will move and can
change and things like that
but um
uh
it's you know i see it as a continuing
story
but at the same time each season has its
own identity to it uh and you know when
we get to season two you'll
hopefully we'll talk again and you'll
say oh i see exactly what you mean
um where are you in the sh like have you
shot pardon me for not knowing but
netflix has been a little bit mysterious
have you shot all uh have you wrapped on
season two like where are you in the
production
yes we've wrapped season two i'm in
editorial on season two and
that's that's what i wanted to know so
um so the plan is for eight episode
seasons uh
like that that's what the number is how
did you guys decide because some shows
are six some shows are 13 and 10. how
did you guys decide on the eight
episodes per season
um
i can't answer that question i think
that that made that that may have come
down from high
you know and and then landed on me eight
is a really good you know um
uh it it
it doesn't sound like a lot but it
really has
what i can accomplish in eight episodes
is going to feel
very weighty i know you've seen the
first five
you know but the last three have it have
their own character as well so i think
that um
um
you know it's
yeah could you could do it with two tin
yeah could you do it with 27
no you know it has a nice feel to it in
terms of the weight well one of the
things about the ada the five episodes
that i saw is it is incredibly fast
moving and i feel like the show
has it's bigger and has more action than
the previous vikings and i'm curious was
did netflix say to you
um you know when when you're writing we
really want this to be action-packed we
really want like did they give you some
sort of you know guidelines or mandates
of what they were looking for with this
viking show
you know steve when when we went around
and pitched it um you know i i
i made that distinction at the beginning
and and and michael hurst was in the
room at that time too and and and
michael writes great action but we we
write totally differently i mean it's
you said the pacing is different on
valhalla than it is from
from vikings i i i made that a part of
the pitch i just said you know look i i
can't write like this guy
i come from a feature action world where
i really love the pace and i think the
audience that
that is in the action world
loves smart shows that just move
characters in and you're having to think
you know you're not three steps ahead of
the audience but you're not letting the
audience say oh man i got this i know
exactly what's going to happen here um i
i hate those type of shows i don't have
patience for those type of shows
and um and i that's my goal every time
is to is to come away saying wow what
happens next you know as opposed to you
know i'm i'm ahead of this show i don't
want that i you know that's a hard place
to get but
i i i um
uh i'm glad you picked up on the patient
because that's one of the big
differences between the two
the you know vikings in valhalla
what did the producers say when you said
to them so listen we're going to have a
long bridge that's going to go into
london and it's going to have a crap ton
of action on it and we are going to beat
the crap like what what are the
producers saying you know the money
people when you're telling them what
you're looking at doing in season one
they they
they went crazy um yeah it's you can
yeah yeah you're you're asking all the
right questions this and i unfortunately
i can't share any of those comments with
you because they're the same but you
know the fact is it's the the great
thing about my irish crew steve is that
they they can do anything
they can do anything
the head space is there they that you
challenge them with this you know with
the ideas like the london bridge and and
they're like how do we solve that so
what we solved is we built four bridges
you know and and we we think ahead the
one thing you know from my background
is you know because i've come in and
done lots of production rewrite work on
big features and the money's spent
you know and when you come in and
rewrite something where the money's
already spent you've got to be smart
about how you do it and time really
helps so if you if you give crafts
people the you know time really talented
people they can do anything and they can
do it for the budgets that you're
talking about but you got to not say
it's impossible you got to say how do we
do this
and and and how do we do it for the
budget how do we make it look 10 times
bigger than our budget
great thing about
you know ireland and that the irish crew
was they had already been doing that
they had been delivering feature style
you know shows
on on you know i love lucy buzzers you
know it's just it's it's it's incredible
what they had been able to do and if if
you know
you're a connoisseur of this this area
so when you look at something you can
sort of say i know how what the vfx is
and what the actual is and what the
practical is you need somehow to be able
to orchestrate all that
so that you can do it and you and you
stay focused on the characters so it's
something because we're not in the
marvel universe we're not gonna you know
blow up this planet we have to make it
very real
uh i'm already out of time but i got to
ask you one other question um i am so
curious about assassin's creed just
because
i have to ask because it's it's for me i
don't think the movies were the way to
go with that property i think it's a
series and there's so much mythology and
depth to that world there's so much you
can do um can you tease people like how
it's coming along and what you're
looking to do with it
i can't tease you at all but i can have
another conversation another time
okay
is that is that a tease enough i mean
it but i i let me just put this way i
totally agree with everything you said
everything
so yeah we'll have we'll have a
follow-up conversation on ac at some
point